[Music]
the title of Grand Master was first
officially awarded in 1950 now in 2017
at the st. Louis Winter Invitational
that tradition continues hello chess
fans Ben Simon here at the Chess Club
and scholastic center of st. Louis where
we have a treat for you over the next
week we have a norm tournament two
fields actually going on here at the
club now what is a norm tournament well
basically a norm tournament is how one
becomes or gets on the road to becoming
a grandmaster or an international master
you need three benchmark performances to
get that title and also a rating minimum
as well so one of the ten player
round-robin fields we will have a few
grand masters and then players who are
trying to earn a Grand Master norm
likewise in the second field ten player
round-robin we have a few international
masters and the rest of the players are
the up and comers who are trying to get
one of the qualifications to become an
international master stick with us right
here on YouTube over the next week as we
talk to some of the hopefuls some of
whom have come from all over the world
to participate in this truly
international event and I'm here in the
studio next to JJ Ali mirandy who was
victorious in his first game and JJ show
us show us to the tipping point are some
highlights from this game today yeah
sure we played the Kerrigan defense with
f3 which is not the main line nowadays
but it's interesting line to play a
sharp game in the character I really
don't think like as problems in the main
lines
caro-kann I mean white can play many
other moves he 593 but I prefer to play
f3 line today
there are many moves for black but my
opponent decided to play for those named
line and white generally prefers the
move Bishop f4 but I was in a more
tactical mode so I decided to play this
line where white can't really take on e4
because of Queen h4 check but play at
Queen e2 and Black has many options here
but he decided to take on a three I
wasn't really sure with which piece to
capture but I decided to take with the
Queen because I didn't know what to do
with the bishop on f1 really so I
decided to take with the Queen negative
six Bishop d3
and whites upon down but he has the
bishop pair development advantage in
some space
due to his pawn on d4 and he has a open
F file which he can potentially use in
any attack my opponent played in 97 with
the idea to go each side which makes a
lot of sense but I just stopped it with
Queen e2 with my idea is just to go
Knight of three short castles in white
should have some initiative at least for
the pawn queen e7 night of three
developing and preventing black 25 B six
short castles well I believe like should
maybe go Bishop e7 but really didn't see
Bishop cheaper I mean no problems for
white in my opinion I should have some
big compensation for the pawn at least I
really don't know where black weren't
actually wrong in the game which was
kind of not very obvious they should g5
I want to play 95 all my pieces are
attacking on the Kings side if he goes
Bishop b7 here maybe 95 still it's good
enough because F 30 takes I can take
with the Queen if I would take with the
faun maybe there's cream c5 check and
black would be a tempo up compared to
the game but I can just take with the
Queen and then take on f6 should be
winning 4 right maybe it's better to
just include h6
and try to play something like this but
I wasn't I was pretty pretty happy with
white honestly like 26 if I go 95 I
think my opponent was going to play at
this position where I was not very sure
if I'm winning or not my main intention
was to go Ricky Juan but I wasn't very
certain if I'm winning after I was like
maybe a five trying to hold on somehow
because if I take takes
I was not sure so I just decided to
include Ricky one first
they should be 795 if he takes now I
think this was the important point
check each one if he plays a 97 let's
say now I'm threatening Bishop f6 if my
rook wouldn't be on e1 black would just
take 25 and I'm threatening to play
Bishop f6 right now and if he let's say
it tries to prevent Bishop f6 with the
idea of Queen Queen afraid I just take
on at 7 and this leads to a nice mate
like that maybe there are other ways
this was the line I saw and after c5 I
think it's just leaning for white and a
4 sequence of notes because now the
point of rook e1 is actually to bring up
the rope on e3 my opponent played one
more move Bishop 8 7 and it takes okay
for me and this is just technique that
was Rico very cool now JJ you are not
one of the three grandmasters in the
field so you have something to gain in
this event
tell us about your norm history if you
have one I only have one norm currently
and I missed a couple of norms with only
half the point I passed the 2500 per
year once I'm hoping to make two other
norms as soon as possible and get my
title now you were telling me earlier
that it's not exactly
a completely free ride here at this
tournament because you have some other
commitments here in st. Louis tell us
about school right I study in the st.
Louis University I am studying Computer
Engineering currently and I'm also
attending the classes as well as playing
at the event so I'm both a student and
an active just where who are you most
looking forward to playing in the GM
dorm field well I respect every single
opponent so I really want to play all of
my opponents and I think they are
equally important
well there's a long way to go JJ
congratulations today here at the st.
Louis chess club you're very welcome and
we'll bring you more this is round one
let's take a look after round one in the
GM norm field what the standings are for
seven players the objective erna norm
however the means to doing that differs
for each player for six and a half
points gore vets lang
burke alley mirandy and kumar can earn a
GM norm for only six points
Cheka and a bohemian can earn a GM norm
and additionally Believe It or Not for
four and a half points Kumar and Abraham
Ian are eligible for an IM norm in this
section alright and now we move over to
the IM norm field and I'm sitting here
with feed a master Josh colas and he was
victorious in his game here today
against national master gritsky
Aaron ger bin ski Josh take us through
some key moments to this game sure so
going into the game it was pretty
interesting because Aaron he's my
roommate in college really really and we
go same school at Webster University and
you know we both know what each other
know each other plays and uh before the
game I my mindset was I'm just gonna
play a normal game and you know hope for
the best
so I started with one g3 and it
transpose into like a English
he played Knight f6 Bishop g2 ecigs out
of three b6
Castle we should be seven
four c5 Knight c3 and here he played 94
now I think this was the this wanted to
keep moments of the game because one has
caught me off guard because I thought he
would just play like a regular Hedgehog
setup but instead he played this move 94
I assumed that he wanted to trade off
pieces right away and you know um
equalized so I captured Bishop takes e4
d4c takes d4 Queen takes d4 now here
it's very tricky because I'm attacking
his Bishop and I'm also limiting limited
Libby limiting sorry his Bishop on f8 -
to stay on to stay on that only one
square because if he moves the bishop
out he's gonna lose the pawn on g7 he
plays d5 I play Bishop g5 here I
calculated this move f6 and now I played
a very interesting move C takes d5 now
if he captures here on f3 Bishop takes
f3 I would capture back and now if he
takes this Bishop I have this nice
smooth queen a4 now this bishop on f3 is
indirectly attacking this rook on a8 and
now he has to do either move his King
out move the Queen let's say he does
Queen d7 out capture he captures what
the knight or the King I would take on
these six I'm going to win one of my
pieces back and I'm going to be up at
least a pawn and in a winning endgame
now the game once
he captured on d5 and I played this nice
move but ship takes f6 here I felt
pretty happy because I knew I was going
to be up a pawn and the worst in the
worst case because if he captures on f6
I would take on f6 with the Queen
I'm attacking his rook on h8 and I have
a lot of threats I have threat to play
rook to d1 with the idea of checkmating
him on d8 and I could also play the move
95 with threat of Queen f7 and I think
after that the game went he I guess he
saw this he played knight c6 and I was
just a pawn in a in a winning middle
game and ended up with the win well very
cool and I I didn't know that he was
your roommate so that's an interesting
side story in itself but speaking of
side stories you were you were telling
me that you had some you had two
different norms already tell us about
the norm situation for you I'm sure I
got mine I have one Jim Norman one I am
norm I got my Jim norm in Vegas in 2015
and that was probably the best tour of
my life
you know I got six and a half out of
nine and I got a Jim norm and VM norm
also count says that I am norm so I got
one GM norm 1 I am norm and I've also
got another I am norm and at the world
open of last year in 2016 so right now I
have to iron norms in one camera so this
could be the big one
very cool well any any parting words
Josh I hope for the best and thank you
to all my fans for the continues of
support well congratulations
maybe we'll see you again this [ __ ]
let's take a look at the IM norm section
standings after just one round seven
players in this field eligible for a
norm
however the means to get there is
different for each player for six and a
half points grab Itsuki hua Benoa colas
Williams and Shankar will earn an IM
norm and due to the tougher field he
will face Doug Eckert only
has to get six points to earn his I am
norm the 2017 st. Louis Winter
Invitational continues through Tuesday
February the 21st follow all of the
action including the live games at us
chest champs dot-com